[Applause]
hello there
so the best ever lego game released and
it's absolutely jam-packed with secret
easter eggs and references so i decided
to put as many as i can into one video
here's 69 of the best
[Music]
let's start with a literal easter egg
get your butt over to hoth and in this
location here you can find this a shiny
easter egg you can interact with it you
can shoot it free but it's a bit of a
struggle when rey first meets han and
chewie on reappoint you solo take the
time to look around and you'll find a
shipping container which needs a unique
code open it and you shall find the ark
of the covenant the sacred relic it was
also in the raiders of the lost ark
movie in which harrison ford plays indy
and of course he also plays han in star
wars 2. sticking with indiana jones his
hat can be seen in a cut scene briefly
in episode 4 but only if you choose to
put out the fire at this section indy's
hat can be seen flying out of the
airlock as princess leia clings on for
dear life there is a third reference to
indiana jones in the force awakens and
is a call back to this scene in raiders
of the lost ark where indy gets bored of
all the showboating before a fight that
he takes a shortcut here in star wars
han solo is about to pull the trigger
when poe dameron takes charge qui-gon
jinn also gets a movie reference linking
to his on-screen actor liam neeson when
approaching a force user puzzle he will
say
i have a particular set of skills that
will come in handy here a direct quote
from the movie taken are a very
particular set of skills
skills that make me a nightmare for
people like you another movie reference
is here to honor spartacus his fellow
slaves conceal his identity by shouting
i'm spartacus
i'm spartacus so lego star wars did this
with padme i am queen amidala i am queen
amidala no
i am
and when chewie and han are planting
explosives it's possible to recreate the
mission from metal gear solid and move
around incognito in a box
lego star wars the skywalker saga has
brought back a bunch of easter eggs from
previous lego games such as using the
force to bring a mundane table and
chairs to life in the very first moments
of episode 1. it's here all over again
one the community was looking forward to
seeing again were the stormtroopers off
duty relaxing in the hot tub and here it
is in 2022 behind this door you'll hear
a familiar line too this is not the pod
you're looking for this easter egg keeps
giving with another stormtrooper in the
shower close by and another listening to
music on his break from imperial
business this dude can also be found
later in the game having a bath in mos
eisley singing the imperial march he's
so used to something going wrong every
time he gets a wash that he'll say this
why does this always happen when i take
a bath
in a new hope take a look at the knocked
out troops they are seeing stars but if
you get a little bit closer you'll see
that they are actually tie fighters and
x-wings crazy attention to detail the
dazed animation is custom to each
character some will see visible z's as
if they're asleep and ones that are
hungry will dream about food the
previous lego star wars games can
actually be found in game in a new hope
keep an eye on the ceiling to find a
secret area and turn around and you'll
see this it's lego star wars 2 from
2006. here on naboo at the water's edge
you can stumble across the prequel
trilogy cover from 2005. you can also
find this in other places like genosis
and finally down in the catacombs of
mazzy's castle you can find this relic
of a more uncivilized time the cover art
of the force awakens from 2016. during
our escape in the millennium falcon in a
new hope han will say this we need to
get out of here in one seat rather than
7 000 little ones
it turns out this is a nod to real life
as the lego millennium falcon does
indeed have over 7000 pieces do you know
anyone who's actually built that in fact
get close enough to the characters and
you'll see the model numbers on each of
their lego pieces and it lines up
perfectly with real life lego sets a bit
of a throwaway easter egg here but if
you fancy a jump scare in a kid-friendly
game during episode 7 take a look at
some of the shipping containers one of
them will do this
so i'm sure you've noticed the strange
alphabet in some cutscenes the aurebesh
language is indeed a real thing and
thanks to the internet we can translate
these on-screen graphics to uncover more
easter eggs when the fight with vader
begins the text translates to loves the
dark side hates sand we all know
anakin's sand issues darth maul says red
dude with bad attitude count dooku's is
great it says never loses his head and
we all know how he met his demise do it
and during our duel with anakin it reads
x-pod racer and current sith apprentice
and of course darth sidious has one too
also known as the senate i am the senate
not yet django fetch reid's donor for
the clone army and here's a good one
general grievous's handle reads more
sabers than sense in reference to that
meme you may have seen where he holds
over 50 sabres the praetorian guards
have a red dead redemption play on words
with red guard redemption kylo ren has
serious daddy issues i think we can
agree with that and my personal favorite
is the sovereign protectors who protect
but they also attack just when you
thought that meme was gone there are a
bunch more which aren't as amusing but
here they are all the same boba fetts
reads the galaxy's most infamous bounty
hunter jabba the hutts says crime lord
of the outer rim palpatine says emperor
sith lord senate and luke says did you
do it as it's his fault ben became kylo
ren captain phasma is called chrome dome
let's go from fn2199 says traitor raider
and for the knights of ren it says
friends make the worst enemies this
one-eyed beast in the trash compactor
has text which translates to keep one
eye open and the tt 2005 boss says come
get some but interestingly that is not
the easter egg here tt games are the
devs behind the lego games and 2005 is
the year the first game they made
released so tt 2005 is actually an
easter egg of themselves
[Music]
the skywalker saga makes reference to a
bunch of video games and tv shows in
mission titles better call maul is a
play on better call saul the tv show the
south park episode in which incorrect
star wars law is used to bamboozle the
jury the chewbacca defense damn it he's
using the chewbacca defense why would a
wookie an eight foot tall wookie and
loosely this could be another indiana
jones reference raiders of the great
temple could be a mashup of raiders of
the lost ark and a temple of doom oh and
a mission called second breakfast can be
found here in reference to the lord of
the rings we've had one yes what about
second breakfast and to double down on
this on takadana a droid will shout no
one tosses a droid
no one tosses a droid which is a
reference to gimli's line in the two
towers
untitled all back game is a nod to
untitled goose game and in that mission
there is another reference to the
witcher and the glitch which became a
meme when your horse would randomly
spawn and get stuck on top of a roof as
if by magic even the gonk droids get a
few side mission easter egg puns gunk
with the wind you know gone with the
wind and gunkster's paradise yo that was
a tune pretty much every side mission is
a pun on something pop culture related i
just finished a mission called don't go
defacing waterfalls a play on the tlc
song don't go chasing waterfalls let's
just all agree that there are hundreds
of puns and we should move on when finn
ventures back into his old life as a
stormtrooper it's possible to find his
favorite cleaning tool good old buffy he
was in sanitation right he's very happy
to see her
i never thought i'd see you again i'm
sure you noticed this in return of the
jedi after chewie saves the day he
breaks out some michael jackson moves in
celebration
there's a really funny glitch in the
current build of the game and i think
you should try it should you constantly
select the mandalorian grogu will also
spawn in with him you can then duplicate
that grogoo and make a huge team it may
not be an easter egg or an official
secret but it's so good to see look at
this i totally wasted a day worth it in
the 1980s the movie spaceballs released
which was a parody of star wars one of
the characters was a droid named dot
matrix the inspiration behind that was
c-3po with a mop on his head and it so
happens that during your playthrough of
the skywalker saga this will happen to
c3po and it's so convincing lando is
immediately attracted to him wow this
baseball's versions of darth vader gets
a nod too oversized and short another
movie reference can be found when order
66 begins obi-wan will hide under a
ledge and it's shot identically to the
scene when spider-man hides in the movie
the characters themselves all have
animations when left to idle too long
grogu will eat a frog just like in the
mandalorian show and other characters
like anakin have little easter eggs
anakin will get out his lightsaber and
notice that it's turned red the colour
of the sith he frantically tries to fix
it before anyone notices a great nod to
his future demise when pairing up
characters we can trigger unique
dialogue between the two sticking with
anakin take the child version and put
him with vader and listen to this
whoa
that's a cool suit where can i get one
of those patience child
foreshadowing gotta love it my favorite
interaction without a doubt is when kylo
ren meets the sith version of rey ray
tell me about it
[ __ ] if you're old enough you'll
recognize the quote from greece tell me
about it
a musical in which the goody two-shoes
leading lady becomes a rebel at the end
do you remember the meme when everyone
would constantly say did you ever hear
the tragedy of darth plagueis the wise
and then you tell them a hundred times
to please stop saying that well it's in
the game select sidious and one of his
apprentices and you'll get a response
like this
you ever hear of the tragedy of darth
plagueis wise
we can't keep doing this
you have told me countless times
during the game kylo ren's love of being
shirtless is brought up many times so
much so that when paired with rey and
shirtless kylo she'll say this
why does this keep happening don't you
own a shirt the breeze
it's
liberating some characters though get a
little redemption when teaming leia with
jabba the hutt he'll say this
you make me sick
[Music]
some interactions are just plain
outright hurtful like obi-wan's comment
to darth maul
you look taller than the last time i saw
you
poor little guy jar jar binks will use
his superior intellect to take palpatine
at his word i am the senate i have sent
it
and have a listen to the banter between
dooku and grievous
look at the many lightsabers i've
acquired
there are so many more of these
interactions we could make a video all
about it but i'll just leave you with
the one which brightened my day and was
the first thing you heard when you press
play on this video should you team up
obi-wan and general grievous you'll be
given this iconic line hello
i'm adam you're awesome thanks for
watching i'll see you next time